this just in there was a time when teen
vampire movies were made and they were
awesome
[Music]
so the Lost Boys is a classic vampire
movie and a classic 80s movie in general
I mean it has mullets hair bands some
big gay dude rocking out on a saxophone
that's 80s right it has 80 synthesized
music and 80s montage style rock music
the two Coreys
Kiefer Sutherland rocking an awesome
mullet and vampires do I really need to
continue this review to convince you
honestly so the story goes Jason Patrick
his mom and his little brother played by
Corey Haim moved to Santa Carla a play
said to be the largest murder capital in
the world but as corey haim soon finds
out from the self-proclaimed vampire
extraordinaire as the Frog brothers aka
Corey Feldman and some other kid the
place is crawling with blood Stoker's
men but as fate would have it Jason
Patrick while chasing a girl falls in
with a gang of these vampires headed up
by Kiefer Sutherland
like I said rocking an awesome mullet
and other members of the vampire gang
include bill S Preston Esquire which I
think this is actually his only other
role and a couple other members from
Twisted Sister all right now really but
I mean they might his will be
after that the movie is all sorts of
pop-culture classics circa 1987 I mean
the characters are just so exaggerated
like the Frog brothers are these badass
vampire hunters in there what like
sixteen years old
Kieffer's character David totally rides
that line of badass vampire charismatic
vampire and 80s biker punk that probably
gets kicked out of malls a lot ladies
would you really tag that over that I
mean let's be serious now and the climax
of this movie is just all sorts of blood
and hilarity bathtub holy water just
saying and when they bust into the
church to load up their squirt guns with
holy water I mean who doesn't laugh at
that Lost Boys is a 25 year old modern
take on classic vampire lore and if you
thought that statement didn't make much
sense it kind of didn't but that's what
it is I just wish there were more
vampires in the movie so I could have
more vampire death at the end that's
what the end was missing other than
that's great I really don't know if Lost
Boys was created as a deterrent for kids
joining gangs in the 80s I could see
that but I have no idea so if you got
and appreciated the jokes and Hot Tub
Time Machine and you like vampires or if
you just want to see that teen vampire
movies can be classic and awesome Lost
Boys I mean it's not meant to be taken
seriously at all and it's not scare
but it isn't easy watch and it's a lot
of fun 23 years later I mean that's
something in fact I would call Lost Boys
80s tastic
[Music]
wait that's not scary in that awesome
vampire way ah there we go but stay
tuned tomorrow for my next Halloween
movie review hint sure on the cover to
the game Dead Rising there's actually a
disclaimer that says that that game did
not rip off the original movie but I'm
doing the remake not the original
because I want to do the remake duties
but if you like what you've seen here
you want to see more than click right
here to see more
[Music]